Okay, Michael. So this notion of having different features or different
dimensions throw us off has a name and it's called the Curse of Dimensionality.
>> Oh, nice audio effect.
>> I did like that effect in post-production. And
it refers to well, a very particular thing. So let
me just read out what it refers to. As
the number of features or equivalently ,uh, dimensions grows that
is as we add more and more features we go x of 1, x of two then
we add x of three, add more and
more of these features. As those features grows or
as the number of dimensions grow ,the amount of data ,that we
need to generalize accurately also grows exponentially. Now this
is a problem of course because Exponentially means, bad in computer science land
because when things are exponential they're effectively untenable.
You just, you just, you sort of can't win.
>> I think everybody knows that in the sense that if you look,
I've done this experiment actually, if you look in the popular press like,
you know, Time Magazine Or New York Times, USA Today. People will use
the word exponentially sometimes to mean
exponentially, and sometimes to mean, a lot.
>> Yeah that's actually a pet peeve of mine.
The whole notion of,
>> Me too.
>> Oh, it's exponentially bigger. No,
that's, that's not meaningful. If you're
saying I have one point. And then I have another point, and I
want to say this one point is exponentially bigger than this one. That's
meaningless! It's also liberally bigger than
that one. Exponentially refers to a trend.
>> Again, their,their,their not talking about the
mathematical relationship. They just mean a lot.
>> Okay, so they're wrong. And it bothers me deeply but
I'm willing to accept it for the purposes of this discussion. Okay.
Exponentially means bad. It means that we need more, and more, and more,
and more data as we add features and dimensions. Now as a machine
learning person this is a real problem right, because What you want to do,
or like what your instinct tells you to do is, oh ,we've
got this problem, we've got a bunch of data, we're not sure what's
important. So why don't we just keep adding more and more and more
features. You know, we've got all these sensors and we'll just add this
little bit and this little bit, and we'll keep
track of GPS location and we'll see the time of
the day and we'll just keep adding stuff and then
we'll figure out which ones are important. But the curse
of dimensionality says that every time you add another one
of these features. You add another dimension, to your input
space, you're going to need exponentially more data, as you add
those features, in order to be able to generalize accurately.
>> Mm.
>> This is a very serious problem, and it sort
of captures, a little bit of what the difficulties are
in k and n. If you have a di, if you have distance function
or a similarity function, that assumes that
everything is Relevant, or equally relevant, or
important, and some of them aren't. You're going to have to see a lot of
data before you can figure that out, sort of before it washes itself away.
>> [CROSSTALK]
>> Yeah, that makes a lot of sense.
>> Yeah, it seems a little scary. So, you know, I think you
can say these words, and the words sort of make sense, but I think
it helps to kind of draw a picture,
and so I'm going to draw a little picture. Okay?
>> Yeah.
>> All right.